[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wer kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
anspannung vor der premiere als erstes
schweizer band tritt patent ochsner bei
mtv unplugged auf
[Musik]
für die renommierte konzertreihe haben
die berner ihre größten hits nochmals
neu erfunden
srf begleitete die mehrmonatigen groben
hautnah
kommen wir zu schlapp war die antike mit
dem ding muss egal
das ich muss
[Musik]
nun besucht kulturplatz sänger büne
huber zwischen albumrelease und
unplugged tour
[Musik]
das ist eine große geschichte für mich
ist
die reputation
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen als ich teenager war
da gehörte der musiksender mtv dringend
zur sozialisation und damit auch seine
konzert drei mtv unplugged nirvana
orient jörg eric clapton sie alle haben
es getan und somit bedeutet anklagt bis
heute auch prestige prestige dass nun
auch der berner band patent ochsner
zuteil wird
die band die im letzten jahr den swiss
music award für das lebenswerk erhalten
hat steht 32 jahre nach der gründung
ganz weit oben ein guter moment um mit
ihm da oben bilanz zu ziehen zurück und
nach vorn zu schauen mit sänger und
frontmann fehler wurde ich glaube gott
deine oma auf tour
[Musik]
zunächst aber tauchen wir ein in die
aufwändigen konzertvorbereitungen die
ein essay filmteam begleitet hat die
zeit war knapp druck und anspannung vor
den einmaligen live aufnahmen
aus dem wort des schönes ruhiges aber
das ist dass
sie ihr wort lebendig sie aber naja
sportfamilie natürlich dass sie das
eherne gandhi die lauwarmes auch gerne
ganz wegzulassen
alles andere als mittelmaß die premiere
einer schweizer bernd in der legendären
mtv unplugged welt
[Musik]
drei monate zuvor in bern die probenzeit
bedient patent ochsner spielen ihre hits
neu
und rein akustisch
[Musik]
ja
mache von mariat
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wenn die welt uns an der gallinat
cent/minute reichsmark am schloss sich
das album so wie sie sowohl dem motto
andere
atx grundlegend
und das trifft auf seine art ist für
andere daumen szene und das ist das ist
das was mich interessiert es
gibt ja so bestimmt die frage wo einem
zivil macht wo kann ich also doch als
sie zum beispiel sieht programm nicht
dass sein
bester von rund 25 stücken soll es für
die mtv aufnahmen werden intensive
kreative arbeit die appetit macht
[Musik]
patent ochsner ist eine zehnköpfige band
die es seit 32 jahren in wechselnder
besetzung gibt sie zelebriert das
zusammensein
lieder das ist mit diesem schaffen
die bands
wie esso tanke die mahonie geile musik
macht
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
fixer bestandteil eines mtv unplugged
auftritte sind gast musikerinnen und
musiker die von der band eingeladen
werden
[Musik]
ihr verstand dass sie menschlich sehr
gut und dann ist eigentlich klar dass
man sich der musikalische irgendwo
[Musik]
das
dynamik
verleiht und nein die mitgliederzahl
habe ich aber sehr fragil
[Musik]
sogar
lustiger wie es rund das projekt und und
mit auto so material beschäftigt und das
ist das eigentlich interessante story
der zugang zum zu der songs wurden
somit quasi zwingt
mit wachs oder boni auch an von songs
for better und sich klare sicht machte
sich eine akustische anklage hatte sich
mit verstärkten es gibt ganz viele
sachen wo man neue musik findet das ist
schon das ist von von interessanter
stets für mehr dem projekt
[Musik]
ich nehme - vor 50 fans
kugelblitz
[Musik]
ich
habe dort ästhetischen habe ich sie nur
umbenannt in paris geschafft bitte der
letzte treffer mit dem schluss ich
glaube die prozesse das ist wichtig das
tut fokussiert quantas aber auch
schneidigen oder das außer englisch
möglich ist dass der film mit ihm mit
schwierig die balance finden
mitte oktober 2021 casino bern hier
werden an zwei abenden die
konzertaufnahmen stattfinden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die
expansive
gibt und das fantasievolle
[Musik]
newsmax.de das personal stehen das ist
ein großes geschäft für mich ich muss
sagen dass pädophilie einschlagen es
ging die tür auf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das hat
die sache eigentlich gar nicht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
daraufhin wurde dem ruhigen telefone und
die im moment vom oktober revue
passieren bevor
schenkt
sein alter bühnenhaus
was macht das so emotional dass
angeklagt
es ist größe form ganzer unternehmen da
im casino sie 120 grad plötzlich am
brühl blogs die eintrifft die an
technik und catering und tracy was gibt
es ist so unüberschaubar wurde und man
merkt aber plötzlich sie haben gleichen
strick aus ist sehr fokussiert sie sehr
klar und um merck schwarzer audi how
vermitteln die habe ist stark machen
dass die
öffentlichkeit treibt die mtv unplugged
vom ritterschlag bis jetzt mal von gar
nicht wählen die andere trotzdem kunden
glauben ja so richtig gefällt ja und
also muss sie so beschäftigt sie die
ganze corona geschäfte das aus sollte
wieder ein amt wählte mal probiert
verlassen blieb für die beteiligten
nicht nur von seiner band sondern nur im
tier im hintergrund also die technische
nach und die anfragen wegen die heimat
aufwachse plan auf die piste wochen
funktionieren wenn es einigermaßen
sowie der geldwerten hackman und auch
und sonnenaufgang und jetzt kommt sein
sollte gar nicht machen
jerry lampen möglich bis ich möchte
sicher wahnsinnig chance wir hatten der
musiksender mtv jetzt mal ganz gerät
fragt ihre karriere als musiker
begleitet
eigentlich nichts
erspart der 80er jahren ski hat die
video kultur sehr interessiert das ist
wo gott ist da ist so bahnbrechend neues
superstars ethnischer sehr genau und
nach sie die mtv unplugged das hat mich
fasziniert
ich glaube ja
10 6%
möglichst großen
mtv music television dieser
fernsehsender hat die art und weise wie
pop wahrgenommen wird fundamental
verändert läutete eine zeitenwende ein
ja
1981 ging mtv an den start
bund und land eine sensation aus den usa
und das ist viel zu ernst um steven
dankbar in europa der schweiz
24 stunden völlig undenkbar mitgenommen
in ganz europa und dass er dem team
natürlich automation einfach das ist das
sog
[Musik]
[Applaus]
schnell avancierte der spartensender zur
weltweiten plattform nummer eins für
popmusik
[Musik]
diese entwicklung analysiert hat kultur
journalist und autor tobi müller in
place repeat
opel hat schon immer von der großen
teilen vom radio vom plattenspieler von
dokumenten kassetten grad vom mp3 vom
video und mtv rheinwacht nicht weiter
zeit genauso wichtig mit dem text sie
quasi bewegung geht der blick der
teilnehmer vorstellen
vorstellen ließ sich damals tatsächlich
wenig in schweizer stuben es gab gerade
mal fünf musikvideos pro woche mit
sammer gebe musik freunde herzlich
willkommen zur wöchentlichen hitparade
[Musik]
doch international glühten die videos in
endlosschleife wer wie madonna das spiel
mit image und inszenieren beherrschte
wurde zum star
[Musik]
mtv entwickelte sich zum globalen
massenphänomen
[Musik]
zum hort unerhörter kreativität und
einem einträglichen geschäft für die
ganze branche
[Musik]
die plattenfirmen die filme zahlen und
gleichzeitig ein
unglaublicher promotion sbu schon
unglaublich wie die über dem hype der
stellen videos lud mtv zum eigenen
kontrastprogramm unplugged konzerte
leise stadt laut
[Musik]
und verstärkt und intim darauf ließen
sich alle reden
[Musik]
doch mit dem aufkommen des internets
erwuchs dem sender konkurrenz die videos
gab es nun dank youtube auf knopfdruck
zu jeder zeit und nicht bloß wenn sie
das tv programm spielte
darunter litt auch die unplugged reihe
für die seitens mtv europe maria
zuständig ist die musikchefin arbeitet
seit 20 jahren im unternehmen
die international gar nicht mehr so viel
beachtung hatte die wir aber im
deutschsprachigen raum wieder wird ganz
ganz viel liebe und mit ganz viel
kleiner arbeit quasi wieder aufgepäppelt
haben
[Musik]
die meisten deutschen musik größen waren
bei n-tv anklagt mit dabei
nun weitet sich der markt auf die
schweiz als eine der populärsten bands
hierzulande sind patent ochsner die
ideale besetzung für die premiere
[Musik]
wenn man darüber nachdenkt die
zielgruppe wieder von mtv viele denken
dessen doch noch ganz jung und hip sein
muss ist gar nicht sondern es muss halt
einfach dieses verständnis und dieses ja
auch diese diese marke muss sagt auch
getragen werden vom jeweiligen künstler
unplugged ist wieder attraktiv der
sender erhält hochwertigen inhalt die
bands und labels kreieren erfolgreiche
best of alben
und die kosten bis zu einer million
franken stemmen nur teils die
beteiligten
bei patent ochsner war das jetzt
tatsächlich so dass erst auf
sponsorensuche gang wurde also nicht die
sponsoren unterstützen da waren sondern
tatsächlich die sponsoren das ganze
finanziert haben und erst moment später
dann die plattenfirma dazu kam
band neue sponsoren für einen lokalen
markt das liegt laut dem
kulturjournalisten tobi müller im trend
und dann ist es auch so dass im
gegensatz zu den 80er jahre wo mz
musikindustrie klassik globaler bilder
im kopf das wachstum und eine ganze
palette
regionalisieren beobachten
patent ochsner und mtv unplugged beide
marken sind etabliert das publikum weist
ein vergleichbares alterssegment auf und
die pop branche verändert sich regionale
märkte gewinnen an bedeutung
die kooperation hat sich gelohnt
[Musik]
süße music
publishing
[Musik]
viele prominente wie trick
konzertausschnitte und persönlicher
ateliers gibt einiges das
buch zu der mtv unplugged show das
booklet und da vorne ist der ostrock
wurde steckt so gehört das ist jede
mitgestaltet jedes werk ist dass ihre
wunsch sie
die statik machen von dem booklet und
deshalb wird die handschrift der songs
und wieder kompositionen des körpers
nach dem 10 wie schaffen sie das rundum
paket jetzt mir jetzt gehört es geht für
die spielregeln bei mtv unplugged
justiz bringen muss etwas neues bringen
muss gastmusiker bringen bühne sind sie
überrascht musik sie es ist als sei das
während features in rückstand wie patti
smith und kate moss mit demnächst cave
super konnte haben sie das gar nicht
warum nicht franken was wir gar nicht 19
sie wärmen wenn mit guest mühe hatte
stand tom waits stellen randy newman und
nick cave patti smith
ok damit am nachher so ist in tschechien
stamme und spaß das gesetz mit dem urin
zusätze shaker oder wir denen hätte zeox
corp du so nah dran bist
ein der nick cave seid ja super weil das
lied ich glaube der hat der trainer vor
ihm clown übersetzt es von goldman kohl
mit der marke unplugged gibt war nämlich
im deutschsprachigen ausland auch die
größte setzt neue märkte sich ruft hat
die nächste und deutschland trotz 100
natürlich nicht
inzwischen kämen auf deutschland tournee
egal wie frisches 17 tag ohne day off
spiel hier zieht des jahres für das
tauchen also die unplugged sessions
wohnen auf 102 euro im casino bern
[Musik]
baut muss ein für die große hitze und
fans wahrscheinlich immer wieder genauso
wie sie mit kleinert und jetzt unter
anders daher weniger ungestüm
melancholische wie befreiend ist das
aber so soll bis zum neuen sg neues
für mich wichtig sei dann ganz anders
das ist da wo
schönste für mehr entwickelt etwa
aspekte führe sich auf wie dem song
immer der heime sexy aber mit den
usa und aggressiv
die junge truppe von testosteron und das
schaut als 60 jähriger mann nach lyon
ist der bruch
das hat mir gefallen
[Musik]
manche songs alle personen im märz
leider ablehnen neujahr und vier
personen nicht attraktiver war getan das
gilt mit leider das einzig umfeld von
risi viele interviews braucht eben neu
ich leite die seine für sonntag ist es
regnerisch wie zum beispiel bilder von
hinzuführen inspizierte das musikalisch
handgemachten ila ist es ist so dass das
mit struktur vom song eigentlich nicht
groß schlank
bedürfnis caffi
sowjetische note 2 und das ist
vollkommen
verstehen
[Musik]
zu der neue songs gehört durst und
hunger oder durst hunger mit heidi happy
wieso ist sehr wichtig die
vereine verbindet mit der frohsinn jahre
ist so intensiv
ich bewundere ihre musikalität die
bewunderte idee
[Musik]
das verfahren
musste bis 11 der moment
musikdienst in hamburg sie ist oder ist
sophie hunger und sie stammen oder mit
ihrer präsenz ist auch anders ist nicht
wie im naturzoo und ein seehund nimmt
der ruhm wie haben sie das erlebt ja es
ist eigentlich eine ähnliche geschichte
wie 3d
[Musik]
die chance erster blick wirkt sehr
bewundert
die arbeit weil sich ihre
künstlerische front entwickelt ist
suchen und finden
und jetzt sollen klarheit also das ist
sowieso auf der bühne hat mir immer
fasziniert mainzer vorspiel hanni nanni
satz für die schubkraft sich somit die
vom song in die songs entwickelt die
sind so definiert a und nach es ist
schon da und weinte sie hält das ist
schon
wahnsinn
[Musik]
direkt startet im januar 21 450 so etwas
das wahnsinnig viel people also 54 cents
womit dank
des kongresses stand haben wir vorab ist
also mehr weiter endete mit beschäftige
csu zur aussetzung und wie wahnsinnig
langen kampf das sieht es auch rösler
beschäftigen und nach glaubt man sich
ehe probiert fokussiert hat und da
passiert ob ich mit dem sofa oder je
nachdem ob das so lagen sie mit musik
dieses lasters gerichtet womit das
risiko genau das macht schnauze flüge
und wenn man das team der fliegt
plötzlich meinen aber gar nicht
[Musik]
jetzt sind band auch live unplugged zu
was heißt das für die arrangements im
vergleich zum casino bern
es ist also das wäre aber falsch zu er
ist wieder krieg das ist das sich
wirklich inzwischen das konzept mit
neuen schuljahr vater auf die straße
oder wahrscheinlich zu machen
mit einer mit deiner momente wo mary 2
es gibt es bei orange wechsel womit
machte im programm das das das ist grund
sein das geschieht so komponiert das ist
alles viel stoff letzte abt installiert
und so schaffen wir normalerweise
eigentlich nicht also wenn wir durch
billige filme freie und für den profis
aktionen womit müssen
contento sah was wo du denn da das ist
eigentlich gesetzt ein gute energie
[Musik]
auf dem instagram kanal von sas kultur
können sie übrigens auch in eine anklage
drei eintauchen und dort nach echten
perlen fischen unter dem label kitchen
sessions spielen in der küche von
kollegin melissa varela interessanter
schweizer junge bands auf
[Musik]
hier auf sf1 geht es gleich im anschluss
weiter mit der sternstunde philosophie
weg von der muse hin zum schnöden mammon
und zur frage die revolutionäre sind
crypto währungen und wir vom kulturplatz
wir melden uns in einer woche wieder und
widmen uns der kunst des älterwerdens
mit kalibern wie der 96-jährigen
tänzerin lola kasich und dem
weltreisenden ewig hippie helge thema
wert bis
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen mehr kultur
tourismus
[Musik]